tratemos de construir una situación en
la que yo puedo participar del programa
privado público del tesoro de manera que
yo obtenga todos los beneficios que
podría obtener en una inversión
tradicional de títulos tóxicos y no
tenga que cargar con las pérdidas
resumiendo de lo que se trata el
programa es que si yo quiero invertir en
algo digamos que quiero hacer una
inversión de 100 dólares o del 100 por
ciento aquí tenemos el 100 la reserva
federal va a hacernos un préstamo de 85
por ciento y 85 dólares el 85 por ciento
de esto que necesito
y lo que quedan el equilibrio va a ser /
mitad y mitad
entre el tesoro y lo que yo invierta
este es el tesoro y este es el
inversionista privado y que sucede bueno
ya hemos hablado de esto bastante en los
vídeos anteriores en el caso positivo si
esto vale más de los 100 que estoy
pensando la ganancia se dividirá entre
el tesoro y el inversionista en el
aspecto negativo de esto si es que esté
bien vale menos del 85% de lo que se
pagó por él en este caso la reserva
federal es la que recibe la pérdida ya
que no puede recuperar su préstamo
completo y lo único que le queda es
recibir este bien valga lo que valga
aquí la reserva federal no puede ir
atrás los inversionistas mientras el
tesoro ni el inversionista privado para
que le paguen el préstamo de manera que
el inversionista y el del tesoro pues no
sufren tanto de las pérdidas pero como
podemos usar este programa para obtener
los mismos beneficios que se hubiera
obtenido al comprar el bien tóxico
digamos que esté bien tóxico antes de
este programa yo estoy dispuesto a pagar
30 dólares por el título obviamente si
este título valiera 40 dólares el
beneficio serían diez dólares si va
a 50 dólares tendría 20 dólares de
beneficio lo que yo puedo hacer con este
plan obviamente antes de este plan
tendría que tomar esos 30 dólares del
banco y usarlo para comprar estos bienes
que los bancos estuvieran dispuestos a
venderme pero lo que puedo hacer ahora
es decir déjenme tomar el 15% de esto
cuánto es el 15 por ciento de 30 es
cuatro dólares con 50 centavos y usar
eso para invertir en este programa y
esencialmente obtener el mismo beneficio
que si hubiera invertido todos los 30
dólares pero apartando lo que resta del
efectivo ahorrando lo esencialmente de
manera que en el peor de los casos yo
solo pierda lo que invertir vamos a
hacer esto para ver que los números
funcionan como les he comentado en lugar
de invertir todos estos 30 dólares hago
a un lado el 15% esos 450 para
participar en el plan y voy a ahorrar lo
que me queda mis 25 50 como efectivo
y usando estos 450 en el plan les voy a
mostrar que voy a recibir todo el
beneficio como si originalmente hubieran
usado la totalidad de estos 30 dólares
como inversión y obviamente mi pérdida
se minimiza ya que sólo perdería estos
450 y no los 30 dólares completos así
que yo invierto 450 esto es de mi parte
como inversionista privado
el tesoro va a invertir la misma
cantidad que yo invertí
ahora tenemos nueve dólares de
equilibrio lo que es el 15% del
equilibrio total así que la deuda que me
va a prestar la reserva federal es de 51
dólares y aquí les comento que hice los
cálculos antes de comenzar el vídeo
entonces tengo un préstamo de 51 dólares
por parte de la reserva federal y cuál
será el capital total que hemos logrado
juntar aquí ahora tenemos 60 dólares
podríamos usar esos 60 dólares si
alguien estuviera dispuesto a venderme
una podríamos decir de las unidades o de
los títulos por 30 dólares con los 60
dólares podríamos comprar dos unidades o
dos títulos compramos dos de estos por
30 dólares cada uno y bueno porque es
que estoy haciendo mis cálculos de
manera que tengamos dos títulos pues
porque el beneficio se divide en dos
partes iguales y lo compartimos en
partes iguales con el tesoro así que
para establecer una situación en donde
yo tenga todos los beneficios
correspondientes a un título que vale 30
dólares pues tengo que llegar a una
configuración en la que se compre el
doble de estos
al momento de dividir en partes iguales
el beneficio con el tesoro pues obtendré
en limitar el beneficio completo de un
título de 30 dólares veamos cómo salen
los cálculos matemáticos contemplemos
diversos escenarios aquí vamos a dibujar
una tabla donde ponga yo estos diversos
escenarios
y aquí es cuando el título vale 0 cuando
vale 10 cuando vale 20 30 40 50 60
veamos qué sucede en cada uno de estos
escenarios en el primer escenario
estos títulos terminan valiendo nada
cuánto me va a quedar a mí pues bueno si
esto no vale nada pues voy a perder todo
lo que invertir que tanto perdí
bueno pues están los 450 que puse como
inversión privada pero si recordamos mi
inversión total era de 30 dólares aunque
sólo pague 4 dólares con 50 en este
programa me queda el resto de mi capital
25 dólares con 50 centavos el siguiente
caso es si cada uno de estos títulos
valiera 10 dólares ese es el valor de
cada una de las unidades y si cada una
valiera 10 dólares entre las dos
tendríamos 20 dólares lo que no es
suficiente siquiera para pagar el
préstamo de la reserva federal por lo
que la inversión que hicimos también se
pierde pero yo sigo teniendo los 25 50
que aparte tercer caso ahora cada título
vale 20 dólares entre los dos tenemos 40
dólares pero me presta
fue de 51 dólares no alcanza para pagar
todo el préstamo menos para tener un
equilibrio así que también aquí pierda
una inversión de 450 pero sigo teniendo
lo que aparte los 25 50 ahí permanecen
ahora ya estamos entrando en un caso
interesante que pasa cuando cada uno de
estos títulos vale 30 dólares que fue lo
que se pagó originalmente por cada uno
de ellos pues ahora tendré 60 dólares de
manera que me alcanza para pagar los 51
dólares del préstamo y me quedan 9
dólares que se van a repartir entre el
tesoro y mi inversión así que a cada uno
de nosotros nos toca 450 más el capital
que ya teníamos aparte pues va a ser 25
50 más 450 pues voy a tener mis 30
dólares y a partir de aquí los
siguientes casos representan que cada
uno de los títulos vale más el siguiente
caso cada título vale 40 dólares entre
los dos tengo 80 dólares 51 dólares aquí
lo voy a dibujar tengo 80 dólares 51 se
van a pagar el préstamo de la reserva
federal no
están 29 dólares que vamos a repartirlo
en partes iguales la mitad le va al
tesoro la mitad va para mi inversión y
cada uno recibe 1450
así que en este caso tengo mi efectivo
que eso no lo he tocado tengo mis 25 50
y le agrego los 1450 del equilibrio que
recibimos y en total me quedan 40
dólares
y lo mismo va a ocurrir para los
siguientes casos ustedes ya pueden ver
el patrón aquí en los escenarios donde
no hubo ganancia lo más que perdí fueron
los 450 de mi inversión original y en
todos los escenarios positivos
veo que obtengo el valor del título
hagámoslo para el caso de que vale 50
dólares pero yo creo que ustedes ya
saben cómo está funcionando esto así que
cada uno de los títulos vale 50 dólares
tengo 2 en total son 100 dólares se
pagan 51 a la reserva federal
nos quedan 49 que se reparten
equitativamente entre el tesoro y mi
inversión nos queda 24 50 cada uno y
esto es 24 50 le sumo lo que tenía
guardado aparte mis 25 50
y en total me quedan 50 dólares y de la
misma manera ustedes pueden ver que en
el caso de los 60 dólares que vale a
cada título
yo voy a recibir justamente 60 dólares y
aquí voy a dibujar un diagrama de
ganancias aquí tengo un eje aquí dibujo
el otro eje este eje horizontal es el
valor eventual
y aquí voy a poner los valores de cada
escenario 0
son siete escenarios
0 10 20 30 40 50 y 60
así que hay un valor aquí en el eje por
cada uno de los escenarios de aquí así
que en todos estos escenarios obtengo
esta parte de mi capital y ese es el
valor más o menos 25 50 el capital que
ahorre y esto lo voy a tener más o menos
hasta este caso voy a dibujar esta línea
y si alguno de estos títulos combinados
valen más de 51 dólares entonces
comenzaremos a tener cierto valor en el
equilibrio cuál será ese valor esto
dividido entre 2 es 25 50 y a partir de
este valor empezaremos a tener cierto
dinero en el equilibrio así que si
tuviéramos los 30 dólares y de hecho lo
voy a graficar aquí a 30 dólares
tendremos este valor eventual de 30
dólares
a los 40 dólares de valor eventual de
cada título tendremos aquí un capital de
40 dólares también y si continuamos
veremos que de aquí a acá se forma una
línea por lo que nuestra ganancia lucirá
así lo cual es una buena visualización
de lo que el gobierno nos está dando
aquí les mostraré que esto que nos está
dando esencialmente es un seguro en el
siguiente vídeo veremos cómo podemos
evaluar este seguro para darnos cuenta
realmente de lo que el gobierno le está
otorgando a los inversionistas y veremos
que ya que al inversionista se le está
dando un beneficio desproporcionado este
subsidio va a la persona que está
vendiendo el bien pero hablaremos sobre
ello en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
terminar este diagrama de aquí decimos
que el punto en el que comenzamos a
ganar dinero está aquí ya que esto es lo
que gastamos para comprar el título
pagamos 30 dólares por el título por lo
que todos estos de acá son los
escenarios en donde comenzamos a ganar
dinero en los cuales el título vale más
de lo que pagamos por él pero el
equilibrio va a valer algo por encima de
los 25 50
aunque tendríamos una ligera pérdida
pero lo padre de aquí es que si somos el
inversionista privado acá solo tendremos
que invertir muy poquito y no tendremos
pérdidas muy grandes ahora veamos cómo
luciría esta curva de ganancia o de
beneficio si hubiéramos invertido
directamente los 30 dólares sin entrar
en este programa vamos a dibujarla en
otro color y se vería algo así
tendríamos el mismo beneficio pero
nuestra pérdida llegaría hasta cero todo
esto hubiera sido nuestra pérdida y yo
creo que ustedes aquí pueden darse una
idea de que el gobierno le está
ahorrando a los inversionistas toda esta
parte de pérdida se me ha acabado el
tiempo en este vídeo en el siguiente
analizaremos cuánto valdría este
subsidio o este seguro o este beneficio
que nos estaría dando el gobierno
después veremos si es que las personas
están dispuestas a pagar de más por
estas cosas